alors chers internautes les chers
internautes puisque je distingue de
journée cet atout de famille bien sûr je
vous souhaite une excellente année c'est
toujours la même chose on croit toujours
que cette nouvelle année va tout changer
si vous y croyez tant mieux si vous y
croyez pas vous attendre à ce je vous
souhaite une super fête de fin d'année
ne buvez pas trop des ignames aussi tu
vois moi le sam parce que je vois pas
mais au moins tout le monde entre en
sécurité chers internautes
c'est le temps de la nouvelle année je
souhaite avant tout plein de santé
l'amour de votre famille et l'amour de
vos amis est ce qu'il ya vraiment deux
plus importants profitez bien de chagas
temps parce que c'est tous présents que
l'on construit son futur merci à vous et
bonne année bonne année à vous
gros bisous viveo bonne année à tous mes
meilleurs voeux pour 2018
j'espère que cette nouvelle année vous
apportera tout ce que vous souhaitez au
plus profond de votre coeur la santé
l'argent en a réussi car m
l'amour tout au vison aimons nous les
uns les autres dans toutes ses dents
toutes ces polémiques avec ces temps de
merde partout
je crois que l'amour est la plus la plus
belle des armes la plus grande des
réponses est la seule qui coûte pas un
rond